آه كلاريسا ، أنت تشهد
شيئًا يحدث أمام
عينيك في الشوارع ، خذ هذا
وأخبرنا عنه ،
نعم أعتقد أن هذا لا يتحدث حقًا
عن نوع اليأس في هذه اللحظة ،
فنحن نرى مجموعة صغيرة من الناس
وآمل أن تتمكن من رؤيتهم في لقطة لدينا
هنا
، حيث اجتمعت مجموعة صغيرة من الأشخاص في
الساحة الرئيسية وهم يركعون
ويصلون
لأنه في الوقت الحالي هناك
شعور حقيقي بعدم وجود فكرة عما
ينزل في خط الأنابيب
ما هو  في انتظار شعب
أوكرانيا في الساعات القادمة في
الأيام القادمة
والبرد شديد هنا ،
لذا فإن رؤية هؤلاء الناس
راكعين على الحجر البارد
في الصلاة هو أمر
مؤثر للغاية وأعتقد أنه
يتحدث عن
حالة الأوكرانيين العاديين  هنا الذين لم
يفعلوا
شيئًا على الإطلاق ليستحقوا هذا الذين
ليس لديهم أي خلاف مع روسيا الذين
ليس لديهم رغبة في الحرب أو الصراع
والذين
لا يشاركون في الجغرافيا السياسية التي
يقوم عليها كل هذا ومع ذلك من
سينتقل  هم وحدهم الذين يتحملون
العبء
الأكبر كما أسماه ماثيو هذا
الهجوم الكبير متعدد الجوانب من قبل واحدة من
أكثر الجيوش تطوراً في العالم على
دولة مستقلة ذات سيادة.